غرايسون بيري ، البالغ من العمر أربعة أشهر ،
يتوسع بطنه الصغير بسرعة ويتعاقد مع
واحد من العديد من الأطفال الذين يعانون من مرض covet 19
الذين يكافحون من أجل التنفس ، هل تخشى
أن يضطروا إلى إدخال أنبوبه ،
نعم
قليلاً ، إنه أمر مخيف حقًا ،
لذلك آمل فقط أن
أنت تعلم
أنه قادر على التحسن والعودة إلى المنزل.
تعتقد غابيل جوف أن
أصغرها أصيب بالفيروس في
عائلة عيد الميلاد التي تجمع وظيفتها الوحيدة
الآن مع الحفاظ على ابنها
في حالة معنوية جيدة ، أتحدث إليه مثل
صوت طفل صغير أغني  بالنسبة له ،
لا يمكنني الغناء ، لكنه يحب ذلك ، وهو
واحد من ما يقرب من 70 طفلاً يدخلون الآن إلى
المستشفى في تكساس للأطفال ، وهو
رقم قياسي جديد لأكبر
مستشفى للأطفال في البلاد في الأسبوعين الماضيين فقط ،
وقد
زاد عدد حالات الاستشفاء هنا أكثر من أربعة أضعاف.
مؤهلون للحصول على
لقاحات من الأطفال الصغار إلى المراهقين
بدأت رحلتنا المرغوبة
أو لا أعرف حتى أن أيامي
العقول عبارة عن بطاطا مهروسة بدأنا في
29 نوفمبر
أنا وابنتي كانت نتيجة
اختبارهم إيجابية
ابنة فيد إيمي وودروف هايلي ، عيد ميلادها السابع عشر
في اليوم الذي زرناه فيه ، تم
إدخال أنبوب في غيبوبة مستحثة
لمدة شهر تقريبًا ،
ولدت أيضًا منذ ما يقرب من ثلاثة أسابيع
وهي لا تعرف أيًا منها كانت لديها عملية قيصرية
في أماريلو في 9 ديسمبر
إلى جميلة  طفلة صغيرة
تزن ثلاثة أرطال وست
أوقيات ولم ترها
بعد ولم ترها وقد تمت تغطيتها.
المديح السلبي يسوع من بامبا تكساس
انتقلت هالي إلى أماريلو ثم
هيوستن للرعاية المتقدمة
لا تزال غير مدركة لابنتها زيلا فاي البالغة من العمر ثلاثة أسابيع
وهي 900  على بعد أميال في
وحدة العناية المركزة لحديثي الولادة في أماريلو ،
ماذا ستخبرها
عندما يمكنك التحدث إليها ، لا أريد
أن أفكر في الأمر ،
أن ابنتي الصغيرة
بعيدة عن ابنتها الصغيرة ،
ينزف قلبي لها من
متغير omicron الآن.
يستعد أطفال ولاية تكساس الوحيدين
لمزيد من الأطفال المرضى
حيث ارتفعت حالات الإصابة بفيروس
كورونا بشكل
صاروخي  يستمر lience في التحرك ، وتعتقد
أنني لا أعرف كيف يمكننا القيام بذلك مرة أخرى
، ثم نستمر في فعل ذلك مرة أخرى حيث أن
أطفال تكساس يستعدون لموجة رابعة من
فيروس كورونا بالفعل
يشهدون ارتفاعًا حادًا في الأطفال الذين يعانون من
أعراض خفيفة كان آباؤهم يسعون للاختبار
التعثر في الفرز للمرض الخطير
نرى الكثير من المرضى يعانون من
أعراض تنفسية خفيفة ،
السعال ، الازدحام ،
الحمى المعروفة ، وما إلى ذلك ،
أعتقد حقًا أن الكثير منهم يسعون حقًا
إلى الاختبار مثل الموجات السابقة ،
والأطفال الأكثر مرضًا الذين يحتاجون إلى
المستشفى هم  يواجهون صعوبة في
التنفس ، لذا فهم يعانون من الكثير من
أعراض الجهاز التنفسي حيث كنا
نتوقع أن
الالتهاب الرئوي
يحتاج إلى دعم تنفسي لمساعدتهم على
التنفس بشكل أفضل انتشار فيروسي من المتوقع أن
يشتد في الأسابيع المقبلة وحتى إذا
لم يكن متغير أوميكرون شديدًا
المشكلة هي
أنه مع وجود العديد من الأطفال
والبالغين المصابين
حتى لو كانت النسبة
المئوية لمعدل الاستشفاء أقل ،
فنحن ما زلنا أه  يمكن أن نرى المزيد من
الأطفال يدخلون المستشفى خلال
فترة زمنية قصيرة جدًا ، وهذا بالتأكيد يضع
ضغطًا على موارد الرعاية الصحية لدينا
ميغيل ماركيز سي إن هيوستن تكساس